welcome back to Stanford
ssw um today we're going to um uh
continue our discussion on machine
learning with grabs and in particular we
will be visiting a new family of
solutions that can uh do classifications
on graphs so earlier we have been
focusing on the Paradigm of um graph
neur networks and today we'll be with
another different idea here but share a
lot of similar intuition that is called
Labor propagation and uh labor
propagation has a very long history it
is uh like a invented way before graph
NE networks um and it has a a lot of
application Beyond graph as well like
in um yeah uh besides like making
predictions on graphs people have used
it in semi suest learning and a lot lot
of other applications as well so this
will be the topic for
today so here's the uh outline for
today's lecture um the main question we
want to ask is um given a network with
certain labels on some of the noes um
how do we assign the labels to the r of
rest of noes um and for example U
suppose there's a social network we know
some of the noes are frosters um and
some others are fully trusted and how do
you uh find the um like the remaining
fraud fraud noes and the remaining
trusty noes um and as you know this
setting have been investigated through
the idea of embedding based methods and
these node embeddings can either be
generated from random works like no to
whack deep walk that we have introduced
a few lecture specs or we can generate
the no embeddings using graph networks
based on the idea of neighborhood
aggregation and we have seen graph
neuron networks in the past um five uh
different
lectures um and the uh key question we
want to ask today is that are there
alternative ways to uh still make this
predictions on network based on what we
know and predict the unknown node
labels so um here's our setting suppose
we are given a graph um and we know some
of the nodes and usually very a few set
of the noes um uh labels and we want to
predict the labels of the remaining no
in the network um let's say we have this
two classes uh green and red and then we
want to uh make predictions all for all
the remaining gray noes um and uh the
term terminology to describe this
classification is transactive node
classification that we have introduced
uh two lectures back um the reason they
call transactive is because all the
training and validation data um they are
all on the same network so we only focus
on one network we don't need to jange
generalized to a separate Network and
then we know some of the know label and
we want to predict remaining ones so
that's why I call it transductive node
classification and another uh name for
this setting is soal SE semi superise
node classification um and this is kind
of a legacy name to describe the setting
of this uh problem um the motivation is
that um usually the network is huge and
we only know very few labels of the noes
so uh it's kind of not not a Suess
learning Tas where we have a lot of
labels but not like a n Suess learning
task we have no labels at all so uh kind
of an intermediate state so people
sometimes also call it semi superise no
classification so this uh will be a
setting we want to uh discuss
today um and today we're going to solve
this problem using a different uh like a
methodology as we have motivated called
label propagation um and the main
assumption or the main intuition here is
that correlations why it exist in
networks um and um to be more specific
what we mean that we assume nodes that
are connected tend to share the same
labels um and this uh effect as we dive
deeper later actually why it exist in
lot of rural networks so uh this is a
kind of a um like a general assumption
you can always make um for real world
graphs um and to solve this problem
based on this intuition we will
specifically introduce three different
techniques um the first uh is the basics
um of this idea is called Labor pration
um and uh this topic is also quite
important and you'll probably encounter
in this homework too as well how to uh
use label pration to solve a specific
pred problem another um Technique we
call is um correct and smooth and this
is actually the current state of Art me
uh when we make predictions on networks
and it's dominating a lot of benchmarks
and uh the nice of this approach is that
it can really combin label pration and
graph new networks that we learned
earlier so um you can actually like a
utilize the idea from both sides and
lastly we're going to talk about
approach called mask label prediction um
and this is a new content we add for
this year's offering um and the main
motivation that this solution is super
simple to implement and it may be useful
for your course project if
needed um so uh let's get started with
the motivation like why we want to um
like a assign uh similar labels to no
that are con connected and this is based
on the observation that correlation why
they exist in network um and we found
that behaviors of nodes are connected
across the links of the network um for
example usually
the noes that are labeled sharing the
same label they tend to Cluster together
like green there's a green cluster and
the red
cluster and there are some very good
reasons that why this assumption will
hold true especially in real world
networks um and there are two
terminologies here one is called homop
the second called influence and these
two like observations from social
science or natural science can give a
lot of nice intuition that why um this
like correlation why exist in networks
uh in particular for homop we want to
argue that there are certain individual
characteristics of different noes that
leads to the social connections between
these noes and vice versa uh in term of
influence because no are closely tighted
together through their social
Connections in the end they tend to
share a very similar individual
characteristics so these are the to
motivations we have and uh let's uh dive
deeper into the two effects first
regarding homop um homop really means
that the tendency of individuals in a
network tend to bound or associate
together with their
neighbors and it has been observed that
a vast array of natural studies um can
have this homop attributes for example
um the age gender organization roles of
nose usually classic together if they
have similar uh values um some uh
concrete example including on academic
uh academic Network researchers who
focus on the same research area uh tend
to um establish closer connections um
and compared to researchers that does
not belong to the same area this because
they can like a site each other's papers
they may meet at different conferences
Etc and this kind of motivate why those
individual characteristics um kind of
establish those social connections
between different
noes um and this hop is a widely existed
um in social networks and here's like a
concrete example visualization of social
networks and this networks is built
among uh different people and based on
their friendship relationship uh the
colors means the interest of different
people like some people may interest in
sports or some interest in arts Etc
so given this real world uh large
networks we can label each node based on
their interest and we can easily see
from this visualization that um the
color of noes tends to Cluster together
meaning that noes that share similar
labels they are closely connected as
well so that's kind of a concrete
example how homop uh appears in real
world
networks um another um motivation we
have is this notion called influence uh
and the influence says that the social
connections can influence uh individuals
characteristics um for example suppose a
group of people of like a connect
together and they may share their
interest and influence each other let's
say if I have interest in certain
musical preferences then um that may
grow the interest of my peers who are
connected with me as well so this is
kind of what influence is happening in
Real World um and consequently because
this influence exist supposed know that
that are closely connected together in
the end they may tend to share similar
features and eventually similar labels
so that's another way to understand why
this homop and influence uh tend to like
a appear in the
network so so far we have seen some nice
motivations from NEC science why there
are a lot of correlations exist in
networks so the question is how do we
leverage this observation and transform
uh into machine learning Solutions and
they can apply on the semi superise uh
classification that we care about uh in
the
networks um so to show this um we're
going to use concrete example to set up
the problem setting um suppose we have
this network with a lot of noes and some
of the nodes are labeled um for example
this green noes are uh like a label One
the red no are label zero and our goal
is that how we want to predict the
labels for the remaining notes in
Gray um so formally we're always giving
one particular graph and only a very few
of the noes are labeled and our goal is
to find the class uh which is the color
um in our example of the all the
remaining notes and our main assumption
that there's homop networks meaning that
supposed not they're uh close together
they tend to share similar uh
labels so um um to be more concrete we
have this a as the adjacent Matrix um
and Y to be a vector of labels for each
of the node um we consider this binary
classification so not only take zero or
one so uh ywal 1 means that node wi has
class one and equal Z means it C zero
and there are unlabel noes then we wish
to classify our goal is to predict which
of this UNL no are likely to be class
one or class zero so we want to assign a
probabilistic vector for each of the
unlabel
node um so this prob Vector can be
written as this p over YW and this is uh
like a generated eventually based on all
the features and known labels for the
network so we want to leverage
everything we know from the network and
generate this uh py for each of the
green nodes that does not have any
labels so this is um our
setting um and we will focus on this
problem through uh three different
approaches that we just talk about uh we
will first visit the core idea of label
propagation and then talk about how
label propagation can be combined with
graph new network which leads to the
second solution correct and smooth and
lastly we'll talk about a very practical
and uh easy to implement approach called
M label prediction so this is our
approach to solve this problem
setting so we will first talk about
label propagation as the uh first uh
like a foundational like a method in
this area um our idea is that we can
propagate the node logo across Network
so from the no that we know the gr label
to the unknown uh unknown noes and um
our intuition that the class probability
um of a given not V should be a weighted
average of the probabilities of its
neighbors um so concretely for a given
note uh like we we initialize the uh
label of it based on the gr truth label
we have um and for those known we do not
have any information so they are
unlabeled we will just initialize using
a a value of
0.5 um and we will update all the
unlabel nodes uh until the convergence
and this update can happen either in
parallel so we compute um the updated
probability Vector for old noes or we
can also uh do like a random update so
pick some random uh and label noes to
update uh in a certain interation um and
until uh it converts merged or until the
maximum number of iterations reached so
this is the intuition of Labor
propagation and we're going to uh like a
introduce the concrete mathematical form
for this
algorithm so um here is the um math for
label propagation uh we have this update
function that uh like a is that describe
a one specific iteration of label
propagation the input of this iteration
will be the probability Vector um for
each of the node in a certain time Point
T So this PT over yal C so this is um a
two-dimensional Vector tells us the
probability of either or not takes a
value of one or it takes a value of zero
we'll uh time this probability Vector
with the adjacent Matrix and take a
summation so this basically said that I
will sum the um V Vector of all my
neighbors and then we'll uh do a
normalization term so we'll divide the
summ value with the um the summation of
all the Neighbors which is a degree of a
given node so uh basically what is
saying here is that to compute the next
iteration value of a given node we'll
simply take the average of its
neighbor's probability Vector so um is
kind of pretty simple intuition here um
and you may recall that this formulation
is very simp to a mean aggregation
inside a graph your network except that
now we are not really like a learning
any embedding or this is not even like a
machine learning algorithm we do not
learn anything we just use this
algorithm to iteratively update the
labels so there's no trainable
parameters
here and um our uh like a extension here
that suppose we have some strength or
weight information on the adjacent
Matrix so in this case the adjacent m is
no longer binary uh some of the edges
have higher weights some of edges have
lower weights then we can easily replace
this um a Vu from the 01 to the weight
of the
edges um and we will repeat this update
uh until uh like a the final value or
Pro Vector converge to uh within certain
threshold so this is like the exact alms
of how uh lat
works so is best to understand this ARG
through a concrete example so we will
have a random example that describe how
um this label FR Works um in reality so
given this networks we have some of the
noes labeled as a green or as red so for
notes that our devel is green we set
them to one for know that label zero uh
label as red we label as zero and for
for all the remaining gray nodes we'll
initialize them with
0.5 um so this notation uh like a p Yi
means that this given node uh is
probability of equal to one and because
it's a binary classification uh like the
uh like a probability of taking of it
being zero is always 1 minus uh like
this value so instead of treating this a
vector we just treat a scalar um and but
like this idea can generalize to
multiclass classification as well so
this is our initial State like suppose
we just give a network a provided with a
network then we'll initialize all the
noes with this initial
values so now we'll begin our uh
iteration with um label propagation so
uh last say we want to update the
probability Vector um for agreement node
three um based on the algorithm describe
what we do is that we simply uh average
the uh likelihood of each of the
neighbor so um in this case this uh node
three has three neighbors uh which uh
has probability of 0.5 0 and zero So
based on this three neighbors Pro value
we'll take an average and assign the new
value to this uh
noes and you can see that after this
update like the information that we
learn from a given un label node kind of
has changed because uh we observe that
it has two neighbors that are label of
zero so it's likelihood is now lowered
because of it's neighboring like a
neighboring knows prob
value um so similarly we can update um
the remaining noes like a in the network
for example for this node four we'll
also look at this four neighbors and um
like some of them are like 0.5 some of
them are one and then we we will take
the average of each neighbor probas
value um and this way uh we can get the
updated value for node four which is uh
still 0.5 so um like our intuition or
algorithms guess for a label of uh node
four does not change after this uh label
propagation
question could it be faster if instead
of using the value from the previous
iteration you used whatever the current
value was good find um so um in our case
here we just uh like a derive the
computation for each of the node the
benefit of always using like the Press
layer is that you can paralyze the
computation so instead of Compu
Computing in reality instead of
computing one node at a time you can
compute like a the update value for all
noes in parallel um and in the meantime
I think the algorithm you suggested also
makes sense um so the suggested
algorithm that like we just ignore like
a like a the So-Cal preious state of a
given node so we always update based on
the current value um I think that is
also like a valid algorithm and um also
aligns with our intuition of homop um
but like this is um like a not really
the algorithm we introduce here I think
both algorithm are
valed okay so um so this is like our
random example regarding Computing two
nodes in the network so uh using the
same idea we can uh continue to compute
all of the UN label nodes in the network
say for node 5 uh we can compute it
likelihood to be 0.75
um and after this iteration now we have
the updated value for each of the
unlabeled no in network and you see that
just after this one like a iteration of
update the Val already start to make
some sense right so um so in this case
like the node eight and nine they have
pretty high uh like a predictive value
because they are very close to the label
node um and for this node like a three
as we talk about
it has a pretty low prediction score so
just after one iteration um we already
like a start to make some reasonable gas
on the the label on the
network so next we're going to repeat
this computation for each of label those
and we'll repeat until the value like a
stop to
change so um the convergence criteria we
can um like a Define uh convergence
criteria based on um like when the
change of uh the probabilties value uh
start to be uh like smaller than the
given Epsilon which is a very small
stretchh hold then we can call that the
algorithm has converged and will stop um
like the
update so uh we'll uh like a continue
this uh iteration until we find that in
this iteration three and four you see
the value barely changed and we can in
this case we set the Epsilon to be
0.01 and because we have satisfied the
convergence criteria then we will stop
the algorithm and we'll output
prediction based on the final uh predict
values that we
have so now we can label all the like un
label noes as converged and we can
output our prediction based on the final
integation score so you see that this
algorithms actually pretty simple it
does not involve any trainable parameter
um like it's not really machine learning
just like an algorithm that can operate
on input graph um but in the end it is
kind of very efficient to compute and
also uh tend to be useful suppos this
homop assumption holds true uh in a
given
Network so there are a lot of real
application of this algorithm because
are very simple and efficient to compute
um for example people have used it for
document classification um where the no
are document and then the edges are the
like a similarity between document for
example there are overlap of the words
or sentences in the document and people
have also used on social networks for
example like a Twitter uh social
networks the those could be different
users tweets words Etc um the addes um
could be like a user user edges where uh
users follows each other or user tweets
uh edges that tells that some user
create some uh specific twist um and we
can construct Edge between twist and
words or hashtag Etc and on this uh like
a network suppose we uh Continue to
update a network based on the uh label
propagation algorithm um in the end
we'll be able to classify which nodes
are more popular or have certain
interest um like towards some hashtag
Etc so um this is kind of another good
use case of Labor propagation um and
people have also used it to do St spam
or fraud detection uh and for example on
financial networks to or on email
networks to identify what are the
account that are kind of
fraudulent so this is is the a basic
idea of um labor propagation and it has
been used you a lot of real application
is um
question kind of showed that it it only
converged if there were certain
properties of the graph that weren't
there like it it was or had no byar
components yeah so is it the same thing
with this or will algorith converge
graph yeah great Point using the
algorthm just described it also suffers
from the like a non-convergence issue so
it's not always a case that this
algorithm can converge so in that case
we can also um do some medication for
example randomly like jump the like a
shuffle or like add some random noise to
the like a node Valu similar to what we
seen homework but indeed that is kind of
one limitation of the
algorithm um and actually we will
summarize in this slide as well so this
idea is pretty nice um and easy to
implement but it suffer from some issues
um like like a one thing we just talk
about is that indeed this algorithm does
not guarantee to converge on any
networks um and also like even though it
may converge it would could take a like
a lot of steps to converge so in reality
like on on reasonable side Network
usually people have to like repeat
hundreds or even thousands of iterations
until satisfy satisfying like a label
value is reached um and another major
limitation of label propagation is that
uh it does not utilize any no attributes
so we only propagate the label of the
network uh across the uh from the like a
known nodes to the unknown nodes but we
never really utilize any features or
attribute in the network so this is
another
limitation So based on this issues uh
our question next is that can we improve
this idea of label propagation so that
we can leverage the very useful feature
information um that presented in the
network so this leads to the second
approach uh we want to introduce today
uh that is uh correct and smooth so it
really um combines the idea of label
progression and the idea of machine
learning with predictions on
networks um so the approach of uh
correct and smooth really achieve a lot
of real success over the past uh two
years um so here is like a screenshot we
take a few days back on this OGB
leaderboard leaderboard so OGB is a
so-called open graph Benchmark this is
the like um the largest Benchmark data
set uh for graph machine learning and
there are like hundreds of different
submissions from different teams that
they are competing with um tens of
different data sets so uh you see that
uh C smooth or CNS really tops the OGB
leaderboard so a lot of solutions they
have this component of cor sus um in
their final submission and this approach
is kind of introduced um two years back
so it has been like a dominant the
leaderboard for a long time so that kind
of gives some real motivation that this
indeed very like a uh like a uh very
performing perform pretty well in
reality so um here is the motivation for
uh C SMS uh we have learned this two
approach uh one is regarding label
propagation on networks and another is
uh for graph new network that perform
trainable uh like neighborhood
aggregation on networks um what we see
is that for this labor pration we have
assume that um supposed know that they
are connected they tend to share simil
labels and this will work because uh
this homop feature uh homop like a
phenomenon kind of widely exist in R
World social networks um and this
approach is pretty easy and fast to
compute because um in the end what we
really need is just some uh sparse
Matrix Vector multiplication so it's
very fast to
compute um but the issue is that uh the
approach does not come with uh or does
not leverage the feature information in
the network so our motivation to is to
really leverage such information in the
network um on the right hand side for
graph neur network uh we made assumption
that the label of a given note uh really
depend on this neighborhood structure so
suppose two notes share the same
neighborhood structure we will get the
same embedding for them and then
definitely assume that they should share
the same label and it works because uh
in most uh real world cases uh the nodes
come with very informative features so
by iteratively aggregating the
information across the network we hope
that the ne network will be able to
learn uh useful information from the
network structure and the features um
the like a limitation of GN is that it
is definitely slower than label
propagation because it has tens of
trainable parameter and also the
computation can be irregular meaning
that it will more challenging to
optimize through deep learning framework
um so like our motivation is then can we
assume that labels are correlated and
try to simplify the computation uh like
a for graph NE Network So based on these
two side of like motivation um the
researchers have proposed this uh like
approach correct and
smooth um
question we said here that label
propagation is fast but earlier we also
said that it could be slow to converge
right so what is the like is it still
much faster than this even though it's
potentially slow to converge and like
how many iterations does it take on a
big yeah good point um I think this is
uh this uh claim that um the competation
is fast is regarding one particular
iteration so one par iteration is really
just a one Matrix Vector multiplication
where you have this sparse adjacent
Matrix and some Vector the probability
value for each note yeah but like um
because the convergence not guaranteed
in some cases it's pretty fast but in
other cases pretty like slow suppose it
does not converge um and and then
regardless how slow it is like I believe
in most cases it's definitely faster
than uh training a deep neur Network
because in that case you have to apply a
lot of stochastic grend steps so that
would be definitely even
slower necessarily faster than just
running
yeah I think for inference then like
because you have a train Network then
it's pretty fast
yeah
cool okay so next we're going to like a
like discuss a bit a bit further that
why like we have limitations with graph
graph neur Network and how we can use
the idea of level pration to improve the
prediction of
gns so uh we have seen this figure
multiple times across our lectures um
the idea of GN is really to encode
different notes based on this different
neighborhood structure and suppose we
consider this problem by like a asking
how does g really utilize the label
information in the network uh we will
found that GN is kind of using the label
information very indirectly in the sense
that we only use the labels to train um
the ways of a neural network and then
after getting the train network will
make predictions for um different nodes
and we can find that the prediction for
nodes are fully independent or
uncorrelated because we will apply the
network for like each of the um
individual nodes without uh explicitly
considering their potential correlations
in the network um and in contrast the
idea of the uh label pration that we
just seen it uses the labels in
prodiction pretty directly uh in like a
by directly propagating the nodes from
um like the nodes with labels to the
noes without labels so this is kind of a
uh distinct like a like a important
difference between uh GNN and label
propagation so um here is a concrete
example that why this like making Anor
related predictions may be a problematic
um in this setting uh we are just giving
like a very simple graph structure it is
essentially like a sequence so we have
no V1 V2 up to V6 um that are connected
together it's a line graph or a sequence
um the input to a graph new network will
be the local neighborhood structure so
to incode no V1 uh suppose the neur
network only has one layer uh to encode
no V1 we will look at is one half
neighbor V2 and when we Inc node V2
we'll look at V1 and V3 Etc so this will
be the input to a given graph neural
network and let's examine uh the
predictions and see how the model May
learn from the uh like a ground truth
label to make uh such predictions um and
our claim is that suppose the no
features are overwhelmingly predictive
then making such like uncorrect
predictions for each of the no may be
okay um so what I mean is that those
like um uh like a uh White and uh gray
boxes are the node features and because
in this case the features of different
noes are informative um in the end the
neuron network will be able to generate
different embeddings and therefore make
like a predictions that are aligning
with the labels of the in the original
Network so the claim is that suppos the
features are informative for the
prediction task then this Paradigm of
gns that first computer embedding and
then making the prediction like a is
okay however we can um easily construct
some like a failure mode for this
particular problem uh let's say we're
still giv the same network but then we
are labeling the network with different
colors so uh in this case some of the
know are label U uh red some of them are
labeled as blue um the issue we found
here here that GN will fail to make like
a different predictions uh in this
particular case um and suppose we
examine the input to the GN uh for node
V1 and the input for node V6 uh we find
that the input are exactly the same
because um then like embedding is over
like a small subgraph with two nodes and
one node has a white uh as the like a
node feature another node has a gray box
as the original feature and this is the
same for not V6 right because it has
exactly the same neighborhood structure
so suppose we want to encode this two
noes using graph NE Network then what we
found is that the embedding for not wi1
and W6 are identical and therefore we
will make the same prediction for this
two noes um however remember that uh in
this prediction task we label the noes
differently so on the one hand we label
node V1 as red uh on the other hand we
label the node V6 as blue so this kind
of uh construct like a a contradictory
prediction for uh the gr Tru label and
kind of demonstrate why it could be a
problematic uh like a solution supposed
with GN for this type of
task so this is really like a a problem
we have encountered uh and this is uh
because the features of the nose are no
longer very predictive for the task that
we care about so suppose we simply um
aggregate based on the those
neighborhood structure we are still not
able to like a make predictions for this
particular task um in comparison suppose
we just run label pration um which
ignores non label um sorry ignores no
feature um it will still perform much
better than GN um for example
given the same network uh we remove the
label of node V1 and node V6 and we will
propagate the uh label using the
remaining noes then in the end we will
find that label propagation will assign
very high likelihood for node V1 of
being red and then we'll have very high
likelihood for node V6 um labeling us
blue so label progession although being
simple will kind of fix just f C mode
for graph NE
Network so uh let's formally introduce
uh based on this motivation let's
formally introduce uh correct and smooth
as approach to bridge the gap of graph
in network and then and label
propagation um so our setting um is the
same as we have seen so we have a
network some of them are labeled some of
those are not labeled and then we have
uh lot feature vectors that are
associated with each of the node and
corre and smooth have a three step
procedure uh to make predictions on this
uh semi super learning
setting um the first step is to train a
base predictor and we can later we'll
later visit the options of the base
predictor it can be as simple as a
multi-layer perception that only make
preds for each of the node or it can be
like a fully functional graph Network
uh and then given the base predictor uh
we're going to predict a soft labels for
all of the node but of course this
prediction is not perfect uh based on
the limitations that we have just
discussed so in the final step C and
smooth WE Post process the predictions
based on the graph structure uh we have
and this way we can obtain the final
prediction for all of the notes by like
correcting and smoothing the prediction
so this is the overall
like algorithm outline for
CNS so the first step is to define a
base predictor um that can make the
first round predictions based on the
attributes of the noes and then we can
get a soft prediction for given note uh
like a for example the most simple case
can be uh a linear model or multi-
perceptron uh just build over the node
features um and of course we also use a
graph your network to be such base
predictor um so in our case the what the
base model will do that we will consume
this network as the input and then we
will generate a soft label for each of
the noes the reason it is soft because
uh we are like I'm making a prediction
using a neuro Network and the
predictions um that will be the models
like a like a like gas on the label of a
given note so in most cases it will be a
soft a a predictive Vector so this is
the first step that is we want to set up
a base model and then generate the like
the first uh intuition um of a given
node and then um given the train base
predictor will then uh obtain the soft
label for all the existing node in the
network um so in the idea that that kind
of distinguish um label pration is
that we want to generate prediction for
all of the node in the network um for
labor pration we only generate the like
a like code for the unknown noes but for
uh crack and smooth we really want to
generate the prediction for all of the
noes um and the reason we will talk
about it later that is we want to um
leverage the difference between our
prediction and the gr truth to compute
the arrow and we want to propagate the
arrow across the network um and after
getting this soft predictions for each
of the node in the network um our
motivation is that can we leverage the
graph structure and based on the
Assumption of hopo to fine-tune those
predictions and making them like a more
accurate and more
realistic so next come to the uh central
part of correct and smooth uh which
consists of first correcting the
prediction and then smoothing the
prediction
um so these are the post-processing step
we want to make suppose we have got like
the first round prediction from a base
predictor so the first step is the uh
correct uh stage uh where uh we want to
correct the predictions um made from
these base predictors um based on the uh
graph neighborhood structure um and what
we'll do is to compute the arrow of for
like the no that we have the label and
we want to propagate such erors um
through the network and we'll talk about
in more detail later um and the idea of
the smooth step is then um we will
smooth the predictions across a network
um and essentially smooth step is uh
very similar to we see for label
propagation uh it's just a like a
slightly uh like it only have some
slight variant in the exact formulation
but the basic idea is the same as label
propagation so we'll uh introduce the
concrete step of how to correct the
prediction and then how to smooth the
prediction um so uh first step is uh the
correct step and our key idea is that we
want to expect the arrow in the base
prediction to be poly correlated across
the network um so we kind of slightly uh
change the assumption homop so remember
in homop we assume that um the label of
a given node is highly correlated based
on the network structure um and here the
assumption is that the arrows that are
made through a neural network also have
this homop structure so the arrows are
highly
correlated um and based on this
assumption uh we can get the like a
conclusion that suppose a node like like
The Arrow of a node
increases like a at a certain like a
sorry given a certain node suppose his
arrow is huge we want to argue that um
such Arrow will similarly appear in its
neighbors and um based on this uh
conclusion we find um the exact
algorithm is that we want to spread such
un uncertainty or spat those arrows
across the network to update our
prediction
um here is a concrete example of the uh
correct and correct stage so um as we
said we will uh get the prediction
Vector for each of the node in the
network and that includes the labeled
nodes and because we know the ground
truth label for C noes we'll be able to
compute the arrow that we make for um
those label nodes um for example for
this green node 7 um we know that the
ground truth label should be one Z
meaning that his label is green and we
have the predictions from the base
predictor uh and the prediction was 0.95
and
05 and based on the ground truth and the
prediction we will be able to compute
the arrow so that describes um the arrow
the base model has made on this
particular node um and similarly we can
compute the arrow for all the remaining
label node in the network um and then
for the remaining unlabel nodes because
we never know the ground truth so we
wouldn't be able to compute the
arrow after this uh stage we'll now
characterize um the lab the arrows that
we have made on this
network um and then uh we will uh update
the arrow along the edges or along the
graph structure that we have seen and
this is based on our motivation talk
about earlier that is the arrow follow
the homop structure uh on the
network and in particular we will
diffuse the arrow along the edges using
this uh diffusion Matrix um a to uh that
is defined in the next uh slide so um in
particular the update algorithm uh can
be written as this so we we have the
arrow Vector for each of the node in the
network um we will like a sum the arrow
with the probated arrow with certain
hyperparameter that kind of do a way his
on so um after Computing the arrow
messages and then Computing the
propagated errow message and sum them up
we can get the next step arrow for time
t+ one
and then we'll repeat this process
iteratively um until it converge so this
is uh very similar to label propagation
um and also similar to the page rank
algorithm um so what is this normalized
adjacency Matrix um we'll Define the
this normalized ad Matrix as um the
diagonal matrix of the no degree um
power to the negative uh 0.5 and then um
times adjacency Matrix and then time
this diagonal no degree Matrix and why
this formulation is desirable we will
talk about in the next slide um and in
practice we also need to add a self Loop
to this adjacent Matrix um so that we
can keep or retain the information um
for given note um and this d uh is kind
of the degree Matrix which is a diagonal
matrix tells about um the specific
degree for each of the node in the
network um so this setting is uh first
proposed in um this paper in
2013 so why do we want to have this uh
exact formulation for the diffusion
Matrix um so this is uh based on the
fact that um the uh ion value of this
Matrix are always in the range of 1 to
one um and in particular we can find
that the ion Vector um of this uh like a
normalized diffusion Matrix um is U D1
/2 * one and then the corresponding ion
value is one um the reason for that like
a finding uh can be proved as follows so
we manually um multiply the uh normalize
diffusion Matrix uh with this um ion
vector and we can like a reason that in
the end the uh computer result is
identical to one times um this I Vector
so that kind of conclude first uh this
D1 /2 * 1 is a like vector of this
Matrix and second uh the I value is one
um and this derivation utilize the
finding that um suppose we like multiply
the adjacent Matrix with a o1 vector and
then um it is equal to uh like multiply
the diagonal degree Matrix with the o1
vector because uh by Computing with both
approaches we can get the node degree
Vector so using this property we'll be
able to show that the largest um ion
value of this Matrix is actually one and
we have also find the vector uh so why
this finding is important this is
because with this this uh derivation we
can see that uh this normalized Matrix
is well behaved uh like suppose we power
The Matrix for any K iteration um
because um even with power to the K
iteration they ion values are still like
a controlled within the range of
negative 1 to one um and then the
largest AR value is always one um and
with this nice property um suppose we uh
like a iteratively apply this uh like a
normalized or diffusion Matrix um to a
vector in a given Network um the output
is always normalized so we wouldn't get
like a exploded value of like I suppose
we repeatedly propagate the arrow on the
network so uh in summary this like a uh
slide tells us like why we want to use
this normalize diffusion Matrix to
propagate arrows in the
network um and there's also like
intuitive uh understanding that why this
formulation makes sense um so suppose we
look at uh the specific values of this
normalized um adjacency Matrix uh it is
really like a one over the square root
of Di and square root DJ um and the
intuitive to way to understand this
property is that um Suppose there are
two nodes that are connected and they
have like a very few neighbors of each
other then um this value of AIG J uh is
pretty large um and in this particular
case the value is one because uh each
node has a degree of one and suppose um
these two no are connected but then each
of them has a lot of other neighbors and
in that case uh the value of AI J is
small um because um the degree of each
of the n i and J is pretty large so this
is a kind of intuition to understand
like what is the effect after this
normalization so um having defined this
uh propagation Matrix uh a will will be
able to um diffuse uh the training Arrow
across the network so um using the
concrete example we have a derived here
we will start with computed Arrow B from
the base predictor and the ground truth
and then we will propagate such Arrow
across the network um in this case we
propagate for three
iterations um and then you can see all
the like Arrow vectors are now updated
and we can find that um that some
regions of the network have a a less
erroneous part so in this case um the
errors are smaller for this noes um and
for some remaining part of the uh graph
like um uh like there the arrow are
larger so there are more arrow on this
so like this is kind of the converged
result supposed to apply this Arrow
diffusion for multiple
steps
um and in the end uh like a the way we
utilize this diffuse training arrow is
that we will start uh uh like a summing
up our soft predictions and the diffuse
training arrows so remember the soft
labels are obtained through the base
predictor uh either like a multilayer
perceptron or GN um and then we will sum
the self prediction
with the diffus training arrow and this
will be uh like leading to the uh final
predictions um after this correct stage
um and there's like a uh like a hyper
parameter s that uh scale the prediction
uh uh scale the arrow um of the uh
diffused
arrows so this like kind of finish the
first step of the correct and smooth
where we have the soft prediction and
then the diffuse training Arrow um
um no is fully like a post Prof stage in
the sense that um the model is always
trained directly with the labels uh but
then this like a update on the
predictions is a fully postprocessing
stage question is it possible to apply
this procedure when you are running
inference on a different graph than you
TR on so you don't have access standing
ground truth information for the the new
graph MH um I think it is like not
possible based on the original like athm
here because it is really like a
propagating the arrow so suppos we do
not have ground truths and um like a we
couldn't probably error so that's why in
the beginning of this lecture we talk
about we focus on this uh trans stock
learning setting where we only have one
network but I think uh you rais like a
good point in the sense that uh we could
instead of using this Arrow propagation
we can revert to like some smooth
version of your base predictor for
example you can propagate your um
prediction uh scores for different notes
um and you can still smooth your
prediction uh and that does not rely on
ground truth um as an alternative
over another question about that then
would it be a a a natural idea to take
algorithm to but also include the labels
or predicted labels in the messages that
you're passing so then you solve the
problem that the labels are not in the
messages and also you can apply it in
the inductive setting why why not just
do that instead of all of this so you're
suggesting combining the labels in the G
and message passing yeah uh I think one
uh motivation of this approach is that
this kind of fully model agnostic in the
sense that you can choose any BAS
predictor uh like to make the first
round prediction and then uh like update
the prediction so this is also kind of
another reason why this approach is very
popular because you can always make
prediction with any of your favorite
model and then in the end you update
prediction with the simple approach um
but I think what you sest is definitely
another good idea uh like a how to
directly leverage the label in message
passing and we can uh we will visit like
a simply version in the final of this
lecture with talk about this mask label
prediction I think kind of similar to
what we
proposed um another
question Al is
controlling yeah so uh this skill of as
controls like a how important we think
uh the homop exist in a given network uh
let's say we said s to be very small or
even to zero then basically we do not
believe that there's any homop in the
network structure
uh and on the contrary suppose we set X
to be larger and U kind of we want to
emphasize that the homop Assumption hold
in the network and we want to uh correct
uh the prediction even further
yeah um if let's say my problem is a
graph classification problem can I still
use like masks to basically make this
happen and improve my performance so
basically improve upon the no features
that I had initially for the graph
classification problem um I think for
graph classification um you wouldn't be
able to directly use it uh for the same
reason because um for graph class you
always apply to a new graph and for that
a new or unknown graph you do not have
the ground F so you couldn't directly
use this like a like Arrow propagation
for graph
classification in order to improve my
predictions like during
training I mean let's say if I don't
trust my features I think that there are
some errors in the features that I
put into into the nodes for the
graphs um yeah I think uh you can like
kind of uh diffuse uh or like update
your features of your network but still
like it's slightly different from this
smooth Paradigm but it's more similar to
the label prog idea so instead of
propagating labels you could propagate
features in your network to improve the
feature so um so similar IDE but like a
slightly different from what we
discussed
here okay so now we have seen the first
part of EX how to correct the prediction
based on the arrows made by the model
and based on the network structure um
the next stage of this U CNS uh is
smooth Operator um so this stage is
actually identical to we what we
introduce about lab pration um the uh
the Assumption here that the neighboring
no tend to share the similar labels um
so um in in this case uh for the
training noes we will use the ground
truth hard labels instead of the soft
labels so this is exactly what we see in
the label coration uh right so um
instead of like updating the node we
have the labels we will just always
enforce them to be the ground Cru label
like a one Z or01 and then for all the
remaining unseen or unknown labels
unknown noes we will use what we have
seen um like in the first correct stage
um so so this way we can initiate the
smooth step for the the
algorithm um and then the exact way of
the smoothing um is uh identical to what
we see for the uh like in the um label
propagation uh except that we have this
like a hyper parameter that smooth um
like control like how how strong the
smoothing factor
is um so um what we do here is to uh
diffuse the label across edges um and
update um by setting the like a new
predictive uh predictive Vector for a
given node as the average of its
neighbors um so this is how to interpret
this a * D um and then we will do a
weight sum between the uh diffused
predictions and the original predictions
uh and the weight the weight of this
weighted sum is also controlled by a
hyper parameter and this hyper parameter
basically tells um like how strong we
believe that the labels should be
correlated so um after the smoothing um
you can like a take the uh output of the
correct stage as input and then perform
smoothing for a few iterations and let's
say we do three step iteration and set
the smoing vector to be
0.8 um and one note we want to make here
is that you can find the final
prediction scores are not a rigorous
probability Vector so you find that a
lot of them they do not sum to one um
like after this update stage um so in
the end uh
because we just care about making
predictions uh we will just pick the
class with the maximum score um so what
I mean that for example this uh 74 and
18 they do not Su to one but because we
know that the first class has a higher
predic score then uh the model will
output class one um for this a class
zero for this uh given prediction so um
the the because the AR
the algorithm does not enforce a
normalized prob Vector we will just pick
whichever class has a higher predictor
score um so uh to to summarize uh we
have uh start the corre tools with a
base predictor um and then after corre
Smo uh we get a prediction U like a like
this and we find that the algorithm is
able to correct a lot of mistakes made
by the base predictor um and it it is
kind of very successfully correct those
like issues for example um some no uh
eight and uh no three uh they are
misclassified suppose we only use the
base model uh but after the uh crack uh
and smooth stage um node eight is now
correctly labeled as green and no three
is correctly labeled as red um so this
demonstrate like a why this method um is
able to correct mistakes made uh with a
base
predictor um so in practice uh this
approach uh works extremely well um it
can even predict like update the
prediction with a very simple base pror
like a multi
perceptron um so for example um so
consider this uh node classification
task um so it's called OGB products data
set um with the base model uh you'll
only achieve accuracy of uh 63 which is
pretty low um so suppose we do MLP plus
the smooth stage only uh we can get a
performance of 80% and with the full
correct and smooth approach uh we get
like 84% accy and this is almost already
on par with the um setr performance so
uh this result demonstrate like even
with a simple or naive prediction model
MLP uh after the pro processing of his
predictions uh the model performance can
be greatly
boost um to summarize um the idea of cor
and smooth is to uh use uh the graph
structure and the homop Assumption to
update the prediction uh or
post-processed prediction um and in the
correct step we make the assumption that
the arrows follows the homop Assumption
so uh we can diffuse and uh correct the
arrows um that are made from the base
picture uh and in the smooth step we
have the Assumption of the labels
follows the homop assumption uh and in
this case we will just smoothen the
prediction of the the base prediction um
and this is a variant of the label
propagation algorithm we have seen
earlier um and the strengths of this two
step are controlled by two hyper
parameters uh based on how uh how how
how important you think homop is for
each of the stage um and uh in practice
this Corum is really uh model Gnostic
because uh it can be combined with any
base pror so people has used it uh in
combination with graph your networks uh
quite often as well um and we have shown
a concrete example that cmers can really
achieve very strong performance on this
uh semi surpress uh node classification
problem so it's worth considering
suppose you want to uh like a Implement
your own GM pipeline in
practice
so so far we have talked about um the
idea of Labor pration and then a very
successful uh algorithm called correct
and smooth um in the final part of this
lecture we're going to visit a slightly
different but similar idea called Mass
labor progession and this approach is uh
significantly easier to implement and U
also very
successful um so uh here uh is the idea
of mask level prediction um so still our
main motivation here is to explicitly
consider label label information in the
network when we make machine learning
predictions and this approach is
actually inspired from the bird uh
objective that are widely used in
natural language processing um so the
idea of this uh bird objective um is u a
pre-t tring strategy where we want to uh
make mask or word prediction
um so more concretely give an input
which is a sequence um of different
words um in in this uh Transformer uh
training stage uh what we will do is
that we will randomly mask um some of
the uh like a u input tokens of this
sequence of words um and then we will
let the model to predict um those values
um like a to train the network so um in
the end we will have is to have
partially observed sequence and then
predict the remaining values in the
sequence so this is the motivation of
this mask label
prediction so um in in uh conly we'll
apply the similar approach to uh graph
uh graph uh sorry for note level
classication as well um so the idea is
that um instead of treating labels as
like a some additional attached value to
a given node we will treat the label
directly as features um but of course we
want to like uh make sure that the model
is not cheating so it's not like using
the label to predicting the label itself
um so what we will do is to uh construct
a machine learning setting that we use
partially observed labels to predict the
remaining unobserved um feature labels
um so what it means is that in the
training stage uh we will corrupt the uh
node label Matrix Why by uh randomly
masking a portion of the node labels to
zeros um and then we will treat the
remaining uh uh like a node labels as
additional features of the node so what
we'll do is we just concatenate the node
features uh with the mass node labels so
we treat labels as
features and uh after defining this new
node features we'll use this new node
feature to predict uh the mask not
labels so you can see that uh under this
formulation the model is not cheating
although is kind of explicitly using the
labels of different nodes uh we are
making sure that we always use some of
the node labels to predict the remaining
node labels so this way like there's no
uh direct leakage
of the no labels and this is how we do
at training time and suppose the model
is able to do that like a successfully
in the training time then uh at
inference time we will employ all the
observed node labels uh to predict the
remaining and observed No Label um so
this is what we do for both validation
test Set uh in the sense that we'll
directly concatenate uh like the feature
X uh with the node label y uh as the
updated node feature and then we will
use that combined node feature and
labels to predict any remaining labels
in the data set and you can find that
this approach of setting up the training
and inference uh split uh is very
similar to we have seen in the link
prediction and uh is for good reason
because both approach um can be regarded
as a special type of self super learning
on a network so in this case uh we are
constructing um the uh like objective
based on um what we have in the network
so we'll make sure that we'll use part
of the input as the uh input of the
training and a remaining part of the
like a input as the superation so in
link prediction um like a for certain
edges will reserve some of the edges for
message passing and then using the
remaining edges uh as the separation and
here similarly we reserve some of the
labels as the input for for the network
and then use the remaining of the labels
as the uh supervision signals so that's
why this algorithm looks
similar um so so here this concludes the
idea of mask label prediction and you
can see that is like a pretty simple and
straightforward you are not like
changing any of your machine leing
pipeline um except that you set have the
uh features and the label of the network
slightly different and it can be used
for like any uh pipeline architecture uh
we have
defined um
question you uh connect this third
method to label propagation you explain
how how this setup is propagating the
label M yeah we
find so this this uh setting is like a
not like
directly related to what ien earlier so
in the previous approach of Labor
propagation and CRA and smooth we
explicit propagate the label information
in network through like a like a close
form algorithm um in this case uh the
model is like implicitly uh propagating
the label information across the network
um so this really depends on what like a
model you choose here um let's say we
still use graph neur Network um uh for
this mask label prediction task then in
that sense uh we are still making
propagation because you know GN is
making uh message passing or propagation
uh for from uh certain node features to
the remaining node features and because
um we treat labels as one special node
feature so with GN message passing uh we
are kind of uh also passing the label
label information across the network but
this is kind of relate to what what
model you choose here so suppose you are
not using G and using MP then it
wouldn't have this like a nice property
of propagation um so um so this is kind
of one way to understand this
algorithm um another question can you
explain Contex how is mass label
prediction
transed uh so uh the question is why
this approach is
transactive um so so hly for this
approach um it definitely works for
transactive setting but it also works
for inductive setting um so the reason
is um the setup here uh we do not use
any like a information particular to a
network right so uh we are training a
model um using some of the uh observed
uh labels and then all the features to
predict the unobserved labels so this
approach can be generalized for new uh
like a a new graph because for a new
graph suppose we know some of the labels
then we can still concatenate the
feature and the labels to predict all
the remaining labels so uh this C can
kind of can generalize um netive to
unseen graph as well um and suppose uh
you're asking about trans transactive
setting uh the approach also works
because for a given Network suppos you
train on one special split of the like a
the feature and then the label then you
can still predict for the remaining
unobserved
labels um so um we can conclude what we
have learned in this lecture um so we
talk about three different approaches uh
but really the uh key thing you can key
takeway from lecture is that uh we have
introduce some approach that can
explicitly learn the label information
in the network um so remember like
earlier we focused on graph NE Network
and it's really about how to learn the
structure and the feature so we didn't
explicitly utilize label in those
algorithms but what we learn today is H
three different options that can
explicitly take label information into
consideration and this approach include
uh the basic version of label
propagation that we propagate labels
across Network and it has a more
advanced formulation where we combine
and base predictor and label pration um
to smooth and correct uh the prediction
uh and we also see another way of mass
Labb prediction then directly construct
a machine learning task to uh let the
model in incorporate the uh label
information um and then uh like in the
higher level we have concluded our
discussion on machine learning with
graphs and we have talked about three
main paradigms regarding machine
learning on graphs
including the no edding based methods G
label pration so for no edding methods
it does not use any node attributes it
based on the Assumption of uh we can
train embeddings based on the uh
supposed no no are following this like a
short random works and we construct
positive node pairs supposed they
located in the same random work uh like
a if they call occur in the same short
random work and then um not is of
negative example so uh the idea of noing
bding is like agnostic to the downstream
task is like a one way to construct the
self sofware learning setting the GN is
more principled in the sense that it
learns an iterative neighborhood
aggregation uh function that uh can
process uh the Nal structure as well as
the Nal attributes um and finally today
we introduce a label progr idea which
has a induct piles of assuming the
network follows a homop property and
then it can explicitly incorporate the
label information uh when uh like a
making predictions so these three
paradigms uh have all have like a very
wide application in reality and um to
solve a specific graph measuring problem
you can either choose like one of the
Paradigm here or like would we uh Des
today uh you can combine this different
approach uh for example in correct and
smooth uh it kind of combines graph neur
Network and label
propagation um so with that uh I'm going
to conclude this lecture um thank you
very
much